all right let's now move on
to
the one year anniversary of the january
6 trump riots uh a year minus a day ago
being january 5th this was january 6th
of last year
many of us about one and a quarter
million of you
tuned in to pieces of my coverage of the
trump riots it feels like it was
yesterday it's now been a year in that
year we have seen hundreds of cases
against the rioters move forward who
were clearly trump supporters we have
learned more about yes the plan the plan
the expectation the hope from trump and
trumpists that this or anything would
prevent the certification of joe biden's
win um on january 6th
and uh donnie o'sullivan or donai i
forget exactly how it's pronounced it's
done donnie from cnn he's excellent he
went and interviewed trumpists one year
on from the trump riots have they come
around to reality in any way on what
took place
have they accepted that it was trump
people who did the rioting and joe biden
did win the election
they have not this is one of the most
stunning p if there were a sociological
time capsule to look at a thousand years
from now
this video should be on it let's jump
right into it january 6 attack was not
the republicans nor trump it was the
democrats were behind it all
they're the ones that caused it all do
you really believe that
i know it and there is no way
that
a republican
would act that way and there is no way
that trump had anything to do
with what happened on january 6. this is
the no true scotsman fallacy this is by
definition the rioters couldn't have
been trumpists because no republicans
would ever do that
it's a closed loop
it's doxastic closure it is an
indefeasible statement call it whatever
you want
you cannot reason people out of that
belief because there is no reason as to
why they hold it
you just can't do it by definition the
rioters weren't republicans because
republicans wouldn't riot wow
strong statement what about all the
trump supporters that have been charged
and enticed
because it's all democratic
judges and
people that were on the take from the
democrats
it's been a year since the attack on the
u.s capitol
and because of disinformation denial and
diversion americans don't have a shared
history a shared understanding of what
happened here on that day also i think
the whole reporting of it is a giant
hoax
we are very peaceful people so it was a
total setup to me it was the fbi had set
it up i don't believe that they were
trump supporters that did that right you
said the whole thing's a setup you don't
really believe that do you i do
i do
because trump won the election
they they
they've proven it over and over again i
really don't think trump had much to do
other than people that were supporters
for him
some were involved but i think they were
enticed by
the fbi this is why i say we have to
take very seriously the possibility of
something even worse in 2024 listen to
what these people are saying there's no
there's no entry point
to disabuse these folks of these false
beliefs
and by by you know undercover agents
dear god when i spoke to trump
supporters here in washington on january
6th most were in denial about the
results of the 2020 election do you
accept that biden won the election
absolutely not uh biden did not win this
election
on january 6 we walked with trump
supporters who marched from the white
house where trump was doing a speech
here to the u.s capitol and as we
arrived here that is when the first
security barrier was breached
[Applause]
at the time some trump supporters told
me they were happy with what happened
here at the capitol are you proud of
what happened here today absolutely
i think we should have gone on in and
yanked
the our senators out by the hair of the
head and drug them out and said no more
now understand that
now they say no republican would ever
behave that way anyone who did that
stuff wouldn't be a republican
and yet a year ago here are republicans
saying we should go in there and drag
senators out by their hair so are are
these the people that are the fake
republicans i'm absolutely
standing behind 100 what happened here
today one thousand percent it's terrible
how this election was stolen
federal prosecutors have charged more
than 700 people in connection with the
capital rise and repeatedly documented
the writers support for president trump
but some people in right-wing media have
pushed the dangerous idea that it was
all an fbi plot fbi operatives were
organizing the attack on the capital
there is absolutely no evidence
whatsoever that this was some kind of
false flag event staged by the democrats
or the fbi
what would you say to people who say
january 6th was the biggest attack on
american democracy
but i made all the denial and deflection
i met one trump supporter who said it
was important to be real about what
happened on that day what do you think
of the trump supporters that stormed the
capitol
oh my
you talk about mis
misfound feelings um
seeing the folks from my side of the
state that were there
and they're not the part of the campaign
that we would like to have do you think
some trump supporters that say it's
antifa it's black lives matter
that they know that that's [ __ ] but
they just don't want to admit it's
easier to blame someone else
everyone is afraid to
you know take the blame
so that last point is an important one
and we've talked about it before
do these trumpists literally believe
that trump won
and that the rioters were antifa and the
fbi or is it something they say to
signal that they're on the team and they
accept that sometimes in a war you've
got to tell lies or whatever because of
the greater good we don't really have
the answer to the question the answer is
probably some of them really do believe
it but some of them understand that in
order to show that i'm on the team
it's what i've got to say one year later
and it is as bad as it has ever been
which should really scare us about 2024.
let's take a quick break you can find me
on twitter at dpakman and let me know
your thoughts about these incredible
videos
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video